[Musique]
vidéo qui sera retransmise en direct sur
le site internet du Sénat Monsieur le
Préfet merci beaucoup monsieur le
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs donc oui je je
vais donc présenter donc la la la
l'audition à l'origine était plus basée
sur les Jos mais je comprends que
l'actualité la recentre sur la question
des périmètres de sécurité et de
circulation dans Paris mais pas que hein
puisque hier nous avons j'ai donné
effectivement une interview au journal
Le Parisien et nous avons communiqué
avec la mère de Paris le président du
cojot Tony estangué et le maire de
Saint-Denis puisque Saint-Denis est une
ville qui enceinene Saint-Denis est
particulièrement concerné avec le
village olympique avec le Stade de
France et la piscine la piscine
olympique euh nous avons communiqué donc
sur les périmètres de sécurité et de
circulation applica sur l'ensemble de
l'agglomération parisienne viendront
dans quelques jours maintenant la
présentation des mêmes périmètres pour
les sites qui sont situés en cemarne et
dans les zvelines pour lesquels nous
allons mettre en forme les cartes un peu
comme nous l'avons fait et présenté hier
pour l'agglomération parisienne à savoir
enfin concerné par les jeux à savoir
donc le département des des hautes scèes
de SC saint-nis et et Paris euh donc ce
que nous avons présenté hier c'est
plusieurs choses he je je je l'ai
expliqué dans le détail dans un une
conférence de presse qui s'est tenue à
15h he c'est c'est plusieurs choses
c'est en fait les quatre périmètres qui
qui s'appliquent aux Jeux Olympiques
pour que nos nos nos concitoyens on a
une connaissance le plus en amont
possible et dans un dans un processus
qui est un processus de concertation
hein donc ces périmètres ne sont pas
définitifs et les
règles qui vont les régir ne sont pas
définitivement arrêté elles le seront à
l'issue d'une période de concertation
qui va s'ouvrir à partir de dès la
semainef elle a commencé en fait puisque
dès ce matin je recevais les opérateurs
des réseaux divers et variés téléphonie
gaz électricité pour discuter de ces
sujets et définir les conditions dans
lesquelles leurs opérateurs pourront
accéder ou pas au périmètre bon euh donc
voilà et donc nous allons continuer
cette consultation sur la base qui a été
rendue publique hier pour pouvoir
entendre ce qu'on à nous dire les
principaux acteurs des territoires à
commencer par les élus évidemment mais
aussi les grands acteurs économiques les
professionnels des transports les
professionnels du bâtiment qui sont
évidemment très inquiets par par par les
nos périmètres de circulation et nous
allons dans cette phase de consultation
les rencontrer trèsf régulièrement en
tout cas entendre leur observations sur
ces périmètres
alors donc ça c'est important à rappeler
on est dans une phase de consultation et
évidemment et d'ailleurs je je le dis
d'emblé pour se lever tout
malentendu cette consultation qui va
durer jusqu'à la mi-janvier environ
donnera lieu à un arbitrage définitif
sur les règles des périmètres qui vont
donner lieu à la prise par le préfet de
police d'arrêter hein donc il vont
arrêter ces périmètres il y aura des
mesures de police administrative euh
pour lesquels comme vous le savez je
suis compétent sur toute l'île- de-
France pendant les jeux mais donc que je
pourrais évidemment déléguer à au préfet
de département et en tout état de cause
ces périmètres interviendront seront
fixés sans doute un peu avant les Jeux
donc ce seront sans doute les préfets
qui les prendront mais sur une base que
nous avons communément arrêté hein donc
l'ensemble des préfets île- de France
nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur les
principes que je vais vous donner et
surtout les principes dérogatoires c'est
ça qui est le plus important et c'est ça
qui interroge c'est ça qui va qui a
conduit à au débat qu'il y a eu hier sur
la F fameuse plateforme c'est c'est les
conditions de dérogation d'accès à
certains périmètres alors il y a quatre
périmètres he il y a quatre périmètres
bon je je les cartes sont en ligne sur
le site du du des des sur notre site sur
le site du cojot sur le site de la Ville
de Paris je pense que de nombreuses
communes feront ensuite la même chose et
mettront ses cartes en ligne il y a un
périmètre qui est le périmètre
organisateur qui est un périmètre qui
est très restreint qui concerne le site
soit le site de compétition soit le site
soit le le le site village
olympique un site le le le Trocadero par
exemple qui sera un site où va se
dérouler la cérémonie d'ouverture euh et
puis et puis il y a d'autres une deux
autres catégories de sites importants il
y a les courses les courses en ligne
hein donc il y a des courses cyclistes
il y a un marathon il y a un triathlon
il y a un certain nombre de courses qui
vont se tenir et qui vont se tenir sur
un périmètre en général assez assez long
et sur lequel évidemment euh il y aura
un périmètre également de de de
protection bon euh et puis encadrant la
course et puis j'y reviendrai à la fin
parce que en soi c'est un sujet il y a
la question de la cérémonie d'ouverture
à Paris évidemment donc le périmètre
organisateur c'est le périmètre qui qui
entoure directement le site olympique
bon c'est le premier périmètre celui-ci
il est à la main complète de
l'organisateur c'est le cojot qui gère
ce périmètre il y a un deuxième
périmètre c'est le périmètre de
protection qui est le périmètre de la
Loi antiterroriste hein
euh qui est un périmètre sur lequel qui
est qui est contrôlé par les forces de
l'ordre et qui vise évidemment à éviter
que des individus ne se rendent sur un
site olympique armé ou avec des
intentions de commettre une action
terroriste he c'est les périmètres de la
loi de
2017 donc qui a été a été prolongé comme
vous le savez et donc ces périmètres sil
nous permettent de faire des contrôles
aux entrées et notamment des des
fouilles he palpation qui sont faites à
l'entrée du périmètre et en général sur
l'ensemble des sites c'est périmètrre
correspondent au périmètrre organisateur
en général il y a quelques sites où on
aura des riverins ou des commerces
quelquesuns et il y a le cas particulier
mais je le mets volontairement de côté
et le ministre en a d'ailleurs parlé ce
matin sur France 2 il y a le cas de la
cérémonie d'ouverture où le périmètre de
protection antiterroriste sera plus
large que le périmètre de l'organisateur
qui est en fait la la parade et les
kebas de la scène ça ce sera le pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture le périmètre
organisateur M J Rev viendrait et puis
il y a deux autres périmètres donc alors
les périmètres dont je viens de parler
organisateurs périmètres antiterroristes
ce sont des périmètres qui sont des
périmètres qui régissent l'accès piéton
également évidemment he on ne rentre pas
dans ces périmètres comme on veut et ce
qui est normal bon ces périmètres sont
tout à fait classiques on les pratique à
chaque compétition quand il y a un match
au Parc des Princes il y a un périmètre
de protection il y a un match de foot
périmètre organisateur c'est le PSG
quand il y a un match au Stade de France
c'est ce qu'on fait pendant toute la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est ce que
nous avons fait et puis il y a
évidemment ensuite deux autres
périmètres ce qui fer c'est le 3è et le
4e ce sont des périmètres dit de
circulation le premier est un périmètre
d'interdiction de circulation c'est on
interdit la circulation pourquoi ben
parce qu'on considère que pour des par
mesure de sécurité hein donc c'est une
zone de sécurité j'y reviendrai c'est
très important de comprendre ça c'est un
périmètre où on restreint la circulation
pourquoi parce par que il y a énormément
de de flux de piétons qui parce qu'ils
se rendent au site de compétition qui
parce qu'ils se rendent à la cérémonie
d'ouverture qui parce qu'ils se rendent
voir une course de de cycliste B vont
emprunter ces rues en flux piétonnier et
puis il y a aussi un du passage motorisé
puisque il y a tous les véhicules du
cojot les livreurs les prestataires
voilà ce sont des zones où il y aura une
circulation à la fois déjà assez dense
avec l'organisateur et puis des flux de
piéton et très dense avec un risque
important et j'insiste c'est un
périmètre de sécurité avec un risque
important de voitures bélier Si on ne
procéderit pas des contrôles très
clairement bon donc ce périmètre est un
périmètre par principe d'interdiction de
circulation dans la vraie vie quand on
en fait des manifestations à Paris on
prévoit aussi toujours ces périmètres de
circulation pendant la coupe du monde de
rugby il y avait ces périmètres de
circulation ils existaient sauf que la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est l'espace
d'un mat
c'est un petit peu moins long là on
parle de sites de compétition qui vont
parfois être activés tous les jours
pendant 15 jours bon et puis ensuite il
y a la scène la séquence des
paralympiques qui V vont se dérouler à
peu près sur les mêmes scènes donc le
principe de cette de ce périmètre c'est
interdiction de circulation sauf que à
l'inverse de ce que nous faisons
d'habitude nous avons prévu énormément
de dérogation à cette à cette
interdiction de circulation alors je
précise bien les choses je parle de
circulation routière motorisée hein
c'est ça qui est interdit c'est-à-dire
que les piétons peuvent évidemment
passer et les vélos peuvent également
circuler dans ces périmètres
d'interdiction de circulation on ne
parle que de la circulation routière et
contrairement à ce que nous faisons
d'habitude parce que c'est les Jeux
Olympiques les Jeux Olympiques et parce
qu'à la fois il faut qu'on arrive à
concilier cet impératif de sécurité avec
cet impératif qui fait que bah dans ces
zones là il y a des gens qui vivent que
la contrainte elle n'est pas que sur une
journée elle est sur 15 jours et puis
ensite elle se renouvelle 15 jours après
avec les Jeux paralympiques entre donc
je vous rappelle les dates he 26
juillet 26 juillet 11 août et puis on
repart le 28 août jusqu'au 8 8 septembre
he je je crois je en tout cas voilà ça
ce sont les dates des des des des jeux
et qui euh nous nous conduisent quand
même à des périodes
d'immobilisation de secteurs qui sont
quand même assez longs donc il nous
paraissait draisonnable dans ces
périmètres d'interdiction de circulation
euh de ne pas laisser entrer à titre
dérogatoire un certain nombre de
véhicules parce que sur ces périmètres
il y a des gens qui vivent il y a des
commerces il y a des hôtels il y a des
entreprises et donc nous avons prévu
tout un tas de dérogations qui ont été
listées qui ont été listées dans un
tableau qui a été mis en ligne et qui
est mis à disposition du public et des
grands acteurs qu'ils vont pouvoir
consulter et sur la base de duquel va se
dérouler cette concertation parce que la
concertation qu'on ouvre en vrai elle
porte surtout sur ce sujet Quelles sont
les personnes qui seront autorisées à
rentrer dans ce périmètre d'interdiction
de circulation donc il a il y a toute
une catégorie de de de personnes des
taxis qui déposeraient des taxis qui
déposeraient des clients résidants dans
dans la zone des résidents qui
disposeraient de parking privés des
personnes ayant loué des chambres dans
des hôtels et qui disposent de parking
privés euh des personnes qui donnent de
de de des médecins euh des personnes qui
vont visiter des proches vulnérables
voilà autant de dérogations dont on a
essayé de les faire correspondre à la
vraie vie des gens et à la vraie vie
personnelle et à la vraie vie économique
des gens donc il y a toute une liste qui
a vocation éventuellement à être
complétée éventuellement même à être
élargi donc en fonction de la
consultation qui va s'engager je
reviendrai sur les modalités de contrôle
puisque c'est ce qui pose problème mais
je précise que ce périmètre il est
matérialisé c'est pas un périmètre
fictif il sera tenu par les forces de
l'ordre donc il y aura des barrages de
forces de l'ordre qui laisseront passer
les gens évidemment moi je souhaite que
ça se passe de la façon la plus fluide
possible la plus fluide possible j'y
reviendrai également donc et puis on a
un dernier périmètre un 4è périmètre
autour des sites hein donc qui apparaît
sur les cartographies qui ont été mises
en ligne c'est le périmètre bleu alors
lui le périmètre bleu c'est pas un
périmètre d'interdiction de circulation
c'est un périmètre où on réglemente la
circulation en clair c'est un périmètre
sur lequel nous souhaitons éviter la
circulation de transit c'estàdire qu'on
ne veut pas que ce soit un périmètre ù
ce soit une circulation de passage
c'est-à-dire d'individus qui vont d'un
point A à un point B qui n'est pas dans
ce périmètre bleu qui ne soit pas dans
ce périmètre bleu éviter qu'il qu'ils y
passent donc ce périmètre euh et on
pourra lui en revanche il y a pas de il
y a pas de il y a pas de dérogation
c'est plutôt pris à l'inverse c'est
plutôt un périmètre dans lequel on peut
circuler sauf lorsqu'on est en transit
bon et donc là aussi il y aura des
forces de l'ordre il y aura pas de
barrage aussi ferme que pour le
périmètre d'interdiction de circulation
mais il y aura des contrôles qui nous
permettront de vérifier qu'une personne
n'est pas en transit ce sera en réalité
un périmètre indicatif ce sera un
périmètre qui qui est connu maintenant
et les les les automobilistes seront
puisqueévidemment on ne parle toujours
que de circulation routière motorisé
hein j'insiste à nouveau hein les
piétons circulent librement et les vélos
aussi euh donc ce sera un périmètre où
on sera incité finalement à éviter
d'avoir à entrer dans à entrer dans ce
dans ce ce périmètre quand on a rien à y
faire par contre tous les gens qui ont
quelque chose à y faire soit parce
qu'ils y résident soit parce que ils y
travaillent soit parce qu'ils ont des
proches à visiter pourront y entrer sans
avoir à demander de dérogation sans
avoir à demander de dérogation donc
voilà les voilà les quatre principes
voilà les quatre périmètres alors je
précise je précise évidemment je précise
évidemment que pour les courses sur
route c'est exactement le même principe
hein donc sauf que les courses sur route
en vrai les plus contraignantes elles
ont lieu surtout euh
les weekends hein on a une course
cycliste un marathon course cycliste le
3 et le 4 août c'est un weekend et un
marathon le 10 et le 11 c'est un weekend
bon donc tout ça ce sera quand même
beaucoup moins contraignant et on est
sur des plages horaires qui sont plutôt
de l'ordre de la demi-journée voire la
journée pour la course cycliste mais
c'est en weekend et vous connaissez tous
le principe des cours cyclistes he nous
sommes en pleine discussion avec le
cojot ça sera aussi discuté pendant dans
dans le cadre de la consultation nous
aurons nous allons demander avoir
énormément de points de passage à ce que
de manière à ce que les riverins
puissent passer d'un point à l'autre
évidemment pas quand la course passe
mais ça nous sommes en discussion avec
le cojot et on en parlera évidemment
pendant la consultation il y a une
course qui impact qui est un peu plus
impactante c'est ça se passe pendant les
Jeux paralympiques c'est la course
cycliste en fait l'épreuve cycliste se
déroule sur le même parcours qui est en
scinene saint-niis à l'est du
département et qui fait plutôt une
boucle et et là il y a toutes les
épreuves qui se déroulent sur cette
période donc je n'ai plus les dates en
tête mais je crois que c'est du 4 au 7
septembre on a plusieurs épreuves qui se
déroulent donc on aura quand même une
une une emprise sur voie publique qui
sera assez forte et c'est sans doute là
qu'il faudra qu'on prévoir le plus de
points de passage bien évidemment alors
voilà pour l'économie générale du
dispositif je pourrais répondre après à
vos questions sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture sur le la question de la
plateforme sur la question question de
la plateforme il nous a semblé que pour
les périmètres d'interdiction de
circulation motorisé dans les seuls
périmètres rouges que vous avez sous les
yeux si vous consultez les cartes pour
ces seuls périmètres ça ne concerne pas
les piétons ça ne concerne pas les vélos
et ça ne concerne pas le reste de Paris
on est que dans ces périmètres là pour
ces seuls périmètres qui sont encore une
fois des pratiques habituelles des
services de police il nous a semblé que
il était sans doute plus simple cont
tenu du nombre de dérogations que nous
avons prévu de l'importance des
dérogations que nous avons prévu il nous
a paru plus simple de faire en sorte que
les personnes concernées puissent
s'enregistrer sur une plateforme voilà
l'alternative à ça c'est quoi
l'alternative à l'enregistrement sur une
plateforme avec délivrance
injustificatif évidemment bon ce qui
permet de passer plus simple plus
simplement plus rapidement de manière
plus fluide les barrages et pour le
Riverin qui habite dans la zone il
demande évidemment son justificatif une
fois et c'est terminé et il repassera
les barrages tous les jours sans
difficulté pour gagner le parking privé
de sa résidence comme tous les riverins
pourront le faire quand ils disposent
d'un parking privé même chose pour
toutes les catégories de
dérogation ça nous a paru plus simple de
prévoir une plateforme où on puisse
s'enregistrer à l'avance et recevoir un
justificatif donc
euh l'alternative c'est quoi
l'alternative euh en en en je le disais
hier lors du point presse un préfet de
police plus rigoureux pourrait dire bon
ben à ce moment-là on revient sur les
principes habituels et puis on rest sur
une restriction de circulation assez
forte finalement pourquoi on s'ennuie à
prèsvoir des dérogations si au final on
va avoir des que énormes au barrage euh
bon l'autre alternative effectivement
c'est quand même de laisser rentrer les
gens par dérogation mais de leur
demander des justificatifs dont on aura
pas dont on aura pas défini en amont les
règles qui vont au barrage de police
dire moi je suis rurin mais qui n'auront
pas l'attestation qui correspond qu' ne
seront pas en mesure de le justifier et
que finalement on ne laissera pas
rentrer final finalement on laissera pas
rentrer donc il nous paraissait plus
simple de prévoir une plateforme comme
ça se fait assez souvent comme vous le
savez il y a eu le G7 à Biaritz en 2019
c'est ce qui a été fait c'est ce qui a
été fait il y avait une plateforme
d'enregistrement pour les riverins de
manière à pouvoir justifier de l'accès
au périmètre de mémoire d'ailleurs à
biarit ça concernait aussi les piétons
je rappelle que je ne parle que de la
circulation routière automobile
automobile voilà il nous paraissait plus
simple de prévoir une plateforme avec
justificatif papier QR code comme j'ai
pu le dire dans Le Parisien moi j'en
sais rien on va en discuter dans la
concertation on verra ce que veulent les
gens en général les gens préfèrent quand
même les QR codes parce que ça permet au
contrôle de flasher et les gens passent
on tout ça on en discutera en tout cas
nous nous considérons d'un point de vue
sécuritaire que ce périmètre de toute
façon est indispensable à mettre en
place nous considérons d'un point de vue
de la bonne tenu des JO et que pour les
gens puissent continuer à vivre
normalement qu'il doit y avoir des
dérogations et évidemment le le triangle
de tout ça c'est qu'on puisse contrôler
et la sécurité et le le le le fait que
ces dérogations soient rigoureusement
appliquées bon voilà donc voilà d'où
l'idée de cette plateforme qui euh en
drroit puisque c'est une question qui
qui m'a été posée hier euh j'ai j'ai
entendu donc des comparaisons avec
l'état d'urgence il faut une loi et
cetera bon tout tout le monde se
souvient que l'état d'urgence c'était
quand même des contraintes qui étaient
d'un autre niveau d'un autre niveau on
était sur des mesures où vous deviez
rester à votre domicile euh avec des des
contraintte pénal pénale moi la
contrainte qu'il y a à mes périmètres de
circulation c'est que vous rentrez pas
hein c'est c'est tout vous garez votre
voiture et vous rentrez à pied hein donc
avec des contrainte pénale une série de
mesures qui étaient beaucoup plus
restrictives il ne s'agissait il ne
s'agissait pas de il ne s'agissait pas
évidemment euh de de de d'un simple une
simple
restriction le fait de pénétrer en
véhicule dans une zone et puis l'état
d'urgence c'était une mesure qui était
évidemment applicable sur l'ensemble du
territoire national là où on ne parle
que de quelques zones dans Paris
évidemment dans l'ensemble de la région
Île-de-France autour des autres sites
mais ailleurs qu'à Paris l'impact est
moindre il faut faut j'ai oublié de
préciser ça c'est très important à Paris
l'impact est important parce qu'il y a
des sites éphémères qui vont avoir une
surface plus importante bon il reste il
reste de faible ampleur mais il est plus
important que les sites d'autres régions
et je mets encore volontairement de côté
c'est pour ça que le maire de
Saint-Denis hier était à nos côté je
mets volontairement de côté le le la
situation de la commune de de saint-n
donc le cadre juridique dans lequel
s'inscrit cette plateforme à à à MRE en
place c'est celui d'un arrêté qui a déjà
été soumis à l'acnil qui est un arrêté
du 2 mai 2011 relatif au traitement
automatisé de données à caractère
personnel des nommés fichiers des
résidents des zones de sécurité créé à à
l'occasion d'un événement majeur donc ça
c'est un arrêté dont nous faisons usage
quand il y a ce ce type d'événement nous
sommes bien dans le cadre d'un événement
majeur il s'agit bien de réglementer
l'accès à une zone d'ailleurs je vais
vous en lire le contenu parce que ce
sera beaucoup plus beaucoup plus simple
donc le directeur général de la police
nationale le directeur général de la de
la gendarmerie nationale et le préfet de
police sont autorisés à mettre en œuvre
des traitements de données à caractère
personnel dénommés fichiers des
résidents de zone de sécurité
ayant pour finalité la gestion des
titres permettant l'accès des personnes
ou des véhicules aux zones à l'intérieur
desquelles sont apporter des
restrictions à la libre circulation à
l'exercice de certaines activités afin
de prévenir les troubles àord public et
de garantir la sécurité d'un événement
majeur voilà c'est cet arrêté que nous
appliquons qui prévoit la catégorie des
données personnelles évidemment que nous
pouvons collecter
enregistré et et qui que nous appliquons
qui avait été appliqué à Biaritz que
nous allons appliquer cette cette
occasion en quelque sorte cette zone de
circulation d'interdiction de
circulation ça devient une zone de
sécurité hein c'est une zone de sécurité
au sein de laquelle je vais restreindre
la circulation automobile
sauf la circulation motorisée pardon
sauf pour les catégories d'exception que
je vais donner voilà voilà donc ça c'est
le le le texte qui est en vigueur bon je
je j'ai entendu aussi beaucoup de choses
he sur là mais tout ça évidemmenti je
suis ouvert au débat il y a pas de
difficulté hein beaucoup de de de de
remarques aussi sur quelle est la
bascule qui fait que on passe d'un donc
d'abord le traitement qu'on propose il
est il existe il est autorisé par un
arrêté qui a été vu par l'acnine que les
choses soient bien claires c'est la
situation actuelle et je n'ai pas
l'intention de m'éloigner des conditions
qui sont fixées dans cet arrêté et qui
correspondent parfaitement à nos besoins
on n pas besoin de recueillir énormément
d'information juste ce qu'il faut pour
être certain que la personne a quelque
chose à faire dans la zone où elle se
rend parce qu'elle y a un intérêt parce
qu'elle y travaille parce qu'elle y est
domiciliée parce qu'elle se rend même
peut-être dans un restaurant qui est
situé dans cette zone et que ce
restaurant un parking et qu'elle peut
rentrer en véhicule donc euh je je je je
rappelle hein que l'exigence d'une loi
quand on met en place ce type de
traitement enfin le le Conseil d'État
dans son avis dans l'avis qu'il a rendu
à l'époque sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avait bien rappelé hein que
euh que dans donc l'arrêté pardon 2011
est pris en application de la lo 78
évidemment que le Conseil d'État avait
relevé que cette loi de 78 déterminer
les conditions générales dans lesquelles
peut-être autorisé un traitement de
donné la création d'un telun tel
traitement même lorsqu'il est mis en
œuvre par une personne publique et qu'il
est d'une ampleur importante nécite pas
en principe l'intervention du
législateur mais uniquement un acte
réglementaire c'est ce qui a été fait
avec cet arrêté de 2011 donc le cadre
juridique on n' même pas à le prendre il
existe évidemment je je vous annonce que
je je tout ce que je vous dis là je les
j'échangerai avec l'acnil hein
évidemment he d'ailleurs j'ai j'aurai un
contact récent avec laacnil la delpsj a
des contacts réguliers avec laacnil sur
tous ces sujets pour échanger avec eux
et donc il était rappelé dans ce même
avis du Conseil d'État que le recours à
une loi est cependant nécessaire dans
l'hypothèse où le traitement envisagé ne
peut-être misise en œuvre sans
modification d'une disposition
législative qui fait obstacle ce qui
n'est pas le cas ainsi que dans celle où
le traitement conduit à fixer des règles
concernant les droits civiques et les
garanties fondamentales accordé aux
citoyens pour l'exercice des libertés
publiques et entreinsi dans le champ de
l'article 34 ce qui n'est pas le cas du
dispositif que nous mettons en œuvre
hein ce qui n'est pas le cas en tout cas
à mes yeux du dispositif que nous
mettons en œuvre donc voilà pour les
bases juridiques de ce dispositif j'en
termine quand même avec la cérémonie
d'ouverture qui est un d'un genre un peu
particulier mais qui va utiliser
finalement le même dispositif juridique
pour la cérémonie d'ouver ouverture on
va utiliser le même dispositif juridique
parce qu'on est sur un événement
majeur donc ce sera le même dispositif à
la nuance près que nous allons avoir un
périmètre qui va qui va aussi concerner
les piétons alors il ne s'agira pas
évidemment d'imposer des des
restrictions mais le ministre l'a
rappelé sur France 2 ce matin pour des
des raisons évidente de contrôle et de
sécurité il est bien évident que pour
les personnes qui rentreront dans le
périmètre de protection anti le
périmètre antiterroriste de la cérémonie
d'ouverture que nous mettrons en place
comme nous l'avons annoncé quelques
jours avant sans donner encore
évidemment le le moment de sa mise en
œuvre pour des raisons évidentes de
sécurité évidemment que dans cette zone
contrairement à ce qui va être fait sur
les périmètres rouges et les périmètres
de circulation routière automobile
motorisé nous allons également mettre en
place un contrôle que j'ai annoncé hier
sans en donner les modalités qu'il a une
phase de concertation qui s'ouvre euh
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture il y a des
mers d'arrondissement il y a la mer de
Paris avec laquelle je dois évidemment
discuter nous mettrons évidemment en
place un périmètre qui tout en
permettant aux personnes d'accéder au
périmètre de la cérémonie d'ouverture
évidemment bah sauf le jour de la
cérémonie où il faut avoir un billet
mais en dehors de ces de ce jour de la
cérémonie quelques jours avant il y aura
un contrôle qui portera aussi sur les
piétons dont le le le le les modalités
ne sont pas encore déterminées donc nous
verrons ça pendant la consultation mais
qui va reposer sur le même cadre
juridique que celui que je viens
d'exposer hein voilà ce sera on va on
les les gens devront probablement
s'enregistrer euh pour se rendre dans
certains lieux sur le le le périmètre de
la cérémonie alors encore une fois ce
sont des règles qui sont on retrouve
bien là le même équilibre que celui que
nous recherchons c'est-à-dire à la fois
des règles de
sécurité je vous cache pas qu' je pense
qu'il n'y a pas une délégation étrangère
et par parmi les plus grandes sans doute
très certainement qui qui qui
comprendrait que on laisse des gens
cheminer sur le périmètre de la
cérémonie d'ouverture sans qu'il y ait
un contrôle je je pense que ça n'existe
pas je vous rassure enfin ça n'existe
pas les les gens vont tous nous dire oh
là là mais c'est français comment ils
font ça donc voilà donc il faut il faut
qu'on ait un périmètre de sécurité qui
soit robuste solide c'est le cas il est
bâti il est dessiné dans les cartes que
nous avons produite les modalités
d'accès ne sont pas encore les modalités
d'accès piéton ne sont pas encore
déterminé évidemment nous nous les
connaissons mais il faut qu'on qu'on
concerte qu'on discute mais personne ne
comprendrait que on laisse rentrer les
gens mais en même temps on les laissera
on laisse rentrer les gens sans contrôle
mais par contre on les laissera
évidemment rentrer pourquoi parce que
dans ce périmètre ben il y a des gens
qui vivent il y a des commerces il y a
des restaurants il y a des entreprises
et donc il y a plein de raisons qui font
que on ne va pas empêcher de circuler
sur cette zone sauf que il faudra là
encore probablement s'enregistrer on
délivrera dans un justificative dans des
modalités qu'on va définir et le
ministre l'a rappelé ce matin d'ailleurs
sur France 2 mais la base juridique la
base juridique ce sera exactement la
même voilà donc on n'est pas sur une
restriction majeure sur une atteinte
telle à une garantie fondamentale que il
il ne nous semble pas qu'il soit
nécessaire de prendre une loi nous avons
un arrêté qui régit les zones de
sécurité encore une fois qui sont
définies par par mes arrêtés hein et qui
sont prévus donc par un arrêté de 2011
spécifiquement pour les grands
événements et chaque fois qu'on veut
restreindre l'accès au périmètres de ces
grands événements pour des raisons de
sécurité voilà on est épile dans ce
cadre moi je je n'ai rien inventé hein
donc évidemment et je l'ai dit je vous
le redis j'en terminerai par là monsieur
le Président j'étais un peu long mais le
sujet méritait sans doute ce
développement j'ai été un peu long mais
évidemment moi je suis tout à fait
disposé quand on aura terminer la
consultation dans laquelle évidemment
nous avons prévu de rencontrer les deux
chambres hein je je voilà donc on doit
se rapprocher des directeurs de cabinet
des deux présidents pour euh voir avec
eux quel selon quelle modalité il
souhaitent qu'on leur présente dans le
détail le dispositif mais c'est moins de
présenter parce que présenter vous allez
vous l'avez en ligne que de recueillir
un certain nombre d'observations mais
qui vont être très pratiau pratique moi
peut-être que le président du Sénat ou
ses collaborateurs me diront mais
attendez comment j'accède à tel endroit
comment je est-ce que on aura la
possibilité de et c'est un peu ça
l'objet des échanges qu'on va avoir moi
je suis évidemment tout disposé à venir
évidemment vous rencontrer une fois euh
que nous aurons euh fini cette
concertation qui englobera encore une
fois le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale
moi je suis prêt à venir vous présenter
avant qu'il ne soit rendu public euh
présenter à la mission dont c'est
l'objet le suivi des JO je suis
évidemment prêt à venir vous présenter
le dispositif tel qu'il aura été
définitivement arrêté avant que nous le
fassions à la presse puisque nous avons
convenu hier avec euh madame Idalgo euh
monsieur Estanguet et le maire de
Saint-Denis et c'est ce que feront les
préfets dans leur département nous avons
prévu évidemment de rendre ensuite
public le dispositif définitivement
arrêté de gestion de nos périmètres
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
Monsieur le Président avant de répondre
à vos questions merci Monsieur le Préfet
mesdames les
rapporteurs
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Préfet de Police juste avant en en guise
de préambule rappelez quand même que
cette audition était prévu dans le cadre
de notre mission de suivi de
l'application de la loi sur la
éurisation des Jeux Olympiques avant vos
annonces hier faites à la presse et en
conférence de presse et que donc nous
avons ces travaux dans le cadre de nos
missions de contrôle de l'application
des lois qui sont dévolues à au
Parlement premièrement deuxièmement et
donc du coup on a évidemment de
nombreuses questions à vous poser
Monsieur le Préfet de police sur
l'organisation de ces Jeux Olympiques
dont la date approche et le compte à
rebours et la largement engagé mais
c'est vrai que vous annonce concernant
les zones de périmètres qui étaient
attendu notamment sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture étant donné le caractère
exceptionnel euh je rappelle en d'une
cérémonie d'ouverture qui aura lieu à
l'extérieur ce qui ne s'est jamais vu
euh sans dans n'étant pas dans un lieu
contraint et qui se déroulera le long
d'un fleuve et donc la sécurisation de
cette cérémonie d'ouverture suscitait
beaucoup d'attentes et vous avez en
partie répondu même si nous avons encore
un certain nombre de de questions les
annonces que vous avez fait hier soulève
pour nous déjà un certain certaines
questions relatives à l'imbrication des
différents périmètres nous comprenons
les bases légales entre les les
périmètres de la loi silt dont la
finalité avant tout la lutte contre le
terrorisme plus les périmètres de
sécurisation de l'ordre publici et de
sécurisation routière nous avons avons
un peu de mal à voir comment tout cela
va s'imbriquer notamment en matière de
contrôle sachant que les degrés
d'atteinte aux libertés sont variable
entre des périmètres silt où les
fouilles seront possibles et où il y
aura un contrôle systématique à l'entrée
et les périmètres notamment rouges ou
sur lesquels pourront circuler de
manière motorisée que ceux qui ont une
autorisation avec ces fameuses QR codes
ou formme d'autorisation pas encore
totalement fin et donc première question
c'est comment concrètement cela va
s'imbriquer comment on va passer d'un
niveau à l'autre et quel et et
premièrement
deuxièmement qu'en est-il par des des
d'autres zones qui vont exister comme
celle des fan zon qui était un sujet
aussi de contrôle celle de notamment
relative à la flamme olympique donc on
app tout le parcours de la flamme
olympique avez-vous Pr prévu aussi des
modalités de de sécurisation sur la
concertation vous avez parlé de
concertation notamment sur les
dérogation ou ceux qui seront autorisés
à circuler dans ces zones dites rouges
il y aura-t-il aussi une concertation
sur les périmètres précis de ces de ces
zones et de ces périmètres définis et
puis j'ai une dernière question par
rapport à ce sujet-là parce que
évidemment j'en aurai aussi sur la vidéo
protection intelligente qui est un gros
sujet qui concerne cette sécurisation
mais sur lequelle nous reviendrons
sûrement plus tard sur les autorisations
pour accéder aux zones quelles seront
les contrôles et notamment pour
l'obtention du fameux QR code
d'autorisation d'accès à cette zone
rouge voà mes premières questions madame
de La
Gonterie merci président merci Monsieur
le Préfet de toutes vos explications je
crois que en fait le le comment dire le
l'intérêt jeallis dire les mois pour
certains l'intérêt de de vos annonces
d'hier c'est
que chacun a pris conscience de manière
assez brutale de ce que ça voulait dire
que d'organiser des Jeux Olympiques dans
une ville euh et tout à coup le principe
de réalité a fait que on a réalisé un
certain nombre de choses
euh pour ma part je pense que évidemment
tous les dispositifs de sécurité et de
contrôle sont sont non seulement
justifiés mais nécessaires et attendus
euh reste voir ensuite comment comment
il s'organise je n'ai pas extrêmement
bien compris
euh votre votre explication concernant
la stabilité juridique du dispositif
parce que vous faites référence donc à
une loi qui est assez ancienne alors que
le périmètre silt par principe ne peut
s'appliquer que en vertu de la Loi silt
de 2017 donc j'imagine qu'il va donc y
avoir un nouveau décret et donc une
nouvelle saisine de l'acnil enfin bon
autour de tout ça ça j'ai pas voilà je
j'aimerais comprendre un peu mieux
euh et du coup
euh il me semble que ça veut dire que
selon un certain nombre de cas les
piétons aussi pourrai avoir à justifier
de leur présence et cetera et cetera
dans un certain nombre dans certain
nombre de lieux j'ai tendance à penser
que quelques explications pratiques cas
pratique explication illustration
permettrai que les gens comprennent un
peu mieux de quoi il s'agit mais ça
c'est uniquement une question de Come
c'est pas bon
euh voilà donc ça c'est mon
interrogation j'ai une question plus
enfin précise à à à vous
poser depuis la loi dite Jo
euh nous avons autorisé l'usage de la
vidéosurveillance algorithmique euh la
presse a révélé l'usage notamment par la
Préfecture de Police sauf si c'est
inexact euh par le biais de ces
logiciels de vidéosurveillance
algorithmique une fonctionnalité de
reconnaissance faciale il y aur déjà eu
des une
condamnation de la ville de de daville
sur ce point qu'en
est-il la préfecture de police
utilise-t-elle cette fonctionnalité et
ma dernière question alors évidemment on
parle que circulation périmètres QR code
et cetera donc ça peut paraître un peu
décalé quoi que il y a une upation une
question sur la capacité à recruter
insuffisamment d'agents de sécurité
privé
euh voilà on est assez on est très
intéressé aujourd'hui ou lors d'une
autre audition parce que je suis sûr que
nous serons amenés à vous revoir de
d'avoir un peu d'élément sur ce point
leur nombre leur recrutement leur
formation et cetera et
cetera Monsieur le
Préfet merci donc je pour répondre à ces
deux premières série de question donc
sur le sur l'intégration des des des
périmètres l'imbrication l'imbrication
pardon plus exactement des périmètres
ils sont de nature différentes en fait
hein donc un périmètre de circulation
n'est pas un périmètre de protection
silt où là tous les contrôles tout le
monde quand il rentre et fouillé euh
avec
oui oui sur un périmètre de protection
silt le périmètre de protection piéton
bien sûr piéton oui en véhiculecadré
bleu généralement dans le périmètre
encadré bleu on ne rentre pas en
véhicule he ce sont vraiment les piéton
qui rentre autour du site hein euh donc
ce sont les piétons mais c'est vraiment
le le périmètre qui est au plus près du
site hein il faut que ceux qui nous
écoutent comprennent bien qu'on ne parle
que du périmètre autour du site de
compétition et c'est ce qu'on fait
encore une fois pour la Coupe du monde
de rugby c'est ce qu'on a fait pour la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est ce qu'on a
fait
encore avanthier pour le match
paris-germain Arsenal c'est ce qu'on
fait dans toute dans tout les événements
c'est toujours comme ça hein donc il y a
un périmètre où on est fouillé donc ça
c'est un périmètre de la loi de de 2017
euh
donc les choses plus vivantes quand
c'est à l'occasion d'une manifestation
c'est pour accéder au stade ou que
sais-je là on va parler de quartier
enfin de de zone où les gens habitent
oui mais il y a pas d'habitation dans le
périmètre de protection le périmètre de
protection non le périmètre
antiterroriste de protection il épouse
celui du site d'AC vraiment strictement
sauf pour la cérémonie d'ouverture hein
voilà je je le redis on le met de côté
comment gris oui c'est les zones grises
oui oui et et vous avez le le petit
trait bleu qui entoure les zones grises
qui parfois déborde un peu pourquoi
parce qu'il y a une voie qui arrive et
qu'il faut inclure la voie pour avoir s
un meilleur contrôle donc voilà donc
l'imbrication elle se fait assez
naturellement et tout le reste c'est
libre au piéton en fait c'est libre
d'accès on peut y approcher au plus près
le problème c'est la circulation
routière donc l'imbrication se fait de
manière assez naturelle parce que
finalement ce ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes zones hein ce ne sont pas du tout
les mêmes zones il y a des zones de
réglementation de la sécurité et
d'autres de de de protection de sécurité
et d'autres qui sont aussi prises pour
des motifs de sécurité mais qui ne porte
que sur les véhicules voilà c'est
vraiment ça ce qu'on veut éviter euh sur
la la les fan zones oui vous avez raison
de souligner qu'il y a il y a il y aura
un certain nombre de de Fan Zone hein
dans enfin de c'est c'est les clubs
France hein France 2024 qui qui seront
organisés dans Paris qui seront
évidemment protégés et puis il y en aura
d'autres qui seront tenus à l'initiative
des collectivités locales nous on
souhaite en limiter le plus le nombre
parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il faut
qu'on mobilise beaucoup de dispositifs
de de de de sécurité
[Musique]
euh en tout cas nous n'avons pas
normalement à les protéger hein ce sont
les les les collectivités parce qu'il y
en aura dans toute l'île-de-fance en
faitin et on a souhaité avec le préfet
de région Île-de-France puisque une
partie de ces clubs d'animation sont
sont financés donc avec le préfet de la
région de France on a souhaité enimiter
le nombre quand même he de manière à ne
pas dé multiplier euh le le le la
protection moins pour les forces de
l'ordre finalement que pour les polices
municipales et pour la sécurité privé et
puis le parcours de la flamme oui alors
on y travaille hein c'est un si pour ce
qui est de la zone de Paris
principalement la flamme arrive le 14 et
revient à Paris pour le le le 26 he 2526
en fait hein donc on a un cheminement
qui est encadré avec une bulle mais
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
mouvant et les embarras de circulation
seront quand même assez limités hein
c'est un petit c'est un peu comme une
cour automobile mais tout ça on y
travaille alors la concertation he pour
répondre clairement à votre question la
concertation elle porte sur le tout hein
elle porte sur elle porte sur le tout
c'est-à-dire les conditions d'accès et
les périmètres hein évidemment moi j'ai
des élus qui m'ont déjà évoqué la
possibilité d'étendre le périmètre rouge
légèrement à la marge parce qu'il
considèrent que à tel endroit la
circulation serait dangereuse voilà donc
ou le périmètre bleu pour avoir une
déviation un peu plus en amont donc
qu'on a déjà on va regarder ça et cette
concertation elle porte bien sur le
périmètre et les conditions d'accès je
suis sûr que les les maires
d'arrondissement Parisiens auront aussi
forcément de nombreuses remarques sur
les périmètres et donc la discussion
portera aussi sur ces périmètre sur le
justificatif donc la question clé le
justificatif moi j'ai cité le QR code il
y a deux types de de justificatif hein
soit la personne donc qui veut
bénéficier d'une dérogation encore une
fois pour rentrer dans une zone rouge
j'insiste parce que qu' hier j'ai lu
beaucoup de choses qui étaient
complètement fausses on disait que pour
circuler à pied dans Paris il fallait un
QR code enfin c'est c'est complètement
faux on parle que des zones de
circulation routière autour des sites
qui sont très limités et donc pour avoir
une dérogation pour bénéficier de la
dérogation faut remplir les conditions
il faut que les forces de l'ORD puissent
le contrôler facilement à l'entrée sinon
c'est absolument pas gérable ça devient
ingérable bon encore une fois
l'alternative serait de fermer la
circulation routière et ce n'est pas ce
que nous souhaitons donc il y a deux
possibilités soit il y a une donc
évidemment on remplit les conditions sur
la plateforme on va fournir un certain
nombre de justificatifs j'habite à tel
endroit donc on le justifie et je
m'appelle l'Intel évidemment et donc et
donc il y a un justificatif qui sera
émis donc le ou ou ou un QR code c'est
voilà le sujet il est là-dessus le débat
portera là-dessus
comment micro microro et excusez-moi
monsieur le Préfet mais qui va vérifier
sur la plateforme les justificatifs pour
donner l'autorisation c'est nous c'est
la police nationale c'est c'est la
décision d'accès est une décision
souveraine qui ne peut pas être déléguée
hein ce sera forcément les forces de
sécurité publique ou enfin c'est du
régalien hein dans tout toute dans
toute le droit français bâti d'une telle
façon qu'il a un certain nombre de
missions qu'on peut déléguer toutes
celles qui sont détachables des missions
de souveraineté on peut les déléguer
c'està dire que le recueil des documents
et cetera ça c'est une chose mais le le
le contrôle et la décision d'accès ne
relève que de l'autorité publique et qui
contrôlera évidemment l'aut autorité
publique à l'entrée de la zone de
circulation donc soit avec un
justificatif soit avec un Qir code on
verra ce qui est le plus pratique le
Qrcode ça va beaucoup plus vite hein
donc voilà il faut aussi penser à la
fluidité à la fluidité des passages euh
et et faire en sorte que on on on cause
le moin de désagrément à la fois pour
les forces de l'ordre qui vont avoir des
contrôles mais surtout surtout pour les
riverins par exemple qui voudront
rejoindre leur parking en zone rouge aux
abords immédiats des
périmètres par des sites comment tout en
évitant les fraudes aussi tout en
évitant les fraudes
euh voilà sur le sur
le donc sur la communication d'hier
effectivement elle nous a ramené vous
avez raison madame la sénatrice au
principe de de la réalité hein ça c'est
sûr bon maintenant il y avait il y avait
deux options je vous cache pas qu'il y
avait deux options il y avait une option
qui consistait à dire on va aller
rencontrer les grands acteurs avec nos
documents nos cartes les maires
d'arrondissement les grands
professionnels du secteur eur moi j'ai
rencontré il y a de jours l'ensemble des
acteurs du bâtiment et des travaux
publics d'Île-de- France quand même on
commence déjà à expliquer les choses bon
ben il y avait la solution de consulter
sans rendre publi nos cartes bon vous
connaissez la vraie vie bien mieux que
moi les cartes se seraient retrouvé dans
la presse tout de suite et sans les
explications qui vont avec bon je crois
que ça aurait été catastrophique donc on
a plutôt choisi de de en lien avec
l'ensemble des élus concernés évidemment
avec le la décision a été prise par le
ministre de l'intérieur on on l'a évoqué
on a choisi plutôt que d'avoir à subir
des cartes qui qui auraient fuité ici ou
là parce qu'on s'était engagé dans une
démarche de concertation et que donc
forcément la concertation l'a fait en
donnant des cartes hein on peut pas le
la faire comme ça sur sur feuille
blanche ou simplement avec des
explications orales et donc on a
préféré dire qu'on lancait le processus
de concertation et rendre publique la
base de cette concertation avec les
explications qui vont avec de manière à
invité qu'on se retrouve avec des des
des des avec une une rentrée dans le
monde de la réalité encore plus brutale
que ce que vous disiez à de la gterie
donc voilà donc donc c'est c'est pour
cela que nous avons fait cela est-ce
qu'il y aura une nouvelle saisine de
l'acnil moi je ne sais pas nous on va
consulter l'acnil on va la consulter
évidemment he sur ce dispositif
juridique que Don dont dont dont dont je
vais le dont je viens de parler hein
évidemment on va appuyz sur la lo micro
non non non on s'appuyera pas sur la loi
silt moi je m'appoie sur l'arrêté de
2011 hein euh euh donc voilà je je je je
vais définir une zone de sécurité mais
tout ça je le verrai avec avec l'acnil
hein pour alors là le sujet dont on
parle loil c'est vraiment pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture hein vraiment hein
parce que pour les autres sites il y a
pas de il y a pas de sujet et là on le
périmètre de la cérémonie d'ouverture
c'est évidemment la loi sililt mais
c'est aussi une zone de sécurité c'est
aussi une zone de sécurité où on peut
décider de restreindre l'accès et euh ce
que ce que nous autorise à faire
l'arrêté de 2011 c'est à traiter c'est à
instaurer un système de traitement de
données auin de contrôler une zone de
sécurité au plus près d'un grand
événement c'est ça que nous autorise cet
arrêté donc évidemment j'en discuterai
avec l'acnil sur les algorithmes
évidemment donc ce sera l'objet d'un
autre débat mais nous y travaillons pour
les jeux hein dans le cadre de la
nouvelle loi alors en lien très étroit
avec le ministère puisque c'est le
ministère qui passe le marché donc nous
y travaillons nous avons plusieurs cas
d'usage ça je pourrais vous en parler le
moment venu sans difficulté
sur les sur le la presse a fait état
effectivement d'un logiciel de
reconnaissance faciale d'une société
hein donc moi je donc le ministre a
saisi là là-dessus là n nous nous
n'utilisons pas ce logiciel de cette
société-là après la rocofaciale elle est
elle est permise dans le cadre donc de
en judiciaire he en procédure judiciaire
dans un cadre bien bien précis euh mais
qui elle ne se fait pas avec des
logiciels de à ma connaissance de de
boîte privée hein mais tout ça comme l'a
annoncé c'est le ministre nous aurons
euh il y a une enquête le ministre a
demandé une enquête des inspections
générales euh donc voilà moi je je je
pas nous n'utilisons pas le logiciel
actuellement nous n'utilisons pas ce
logiciel de la société qui a été cité et
euh c'est la question précise qui nous a
été posé à l'époque et c'est ce qui est
sorti dans la presse euh sur la sécurité
privée voilà je moi je n'ai pas de
raison d'être inquiet sur ce sujet à à
ce moment précis hein il y a encore des
appels d'Off il y a encore des lots qui
n'ont pas été euh qui n'ont pas été euh
dépouillés enfin oui pour par pas par
par le COJO euh donc voilà donc il y a
pas de raison de penser que la sécurité
privée sera pas au rendez-vous en tout
cas moi je travaille surtout sur les
plans des forces de sécurité intérieure
c'est déjà un vaste travail puisque nous
allons avoir en moyenne 30000
fonctionnaires de ces militaires de la
gendarmerie voir des des armées sur
Paris et l'île-de-fance 30000 he sur la
zone et même parfois P à 45000 notamment
notamment pour pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture merci Monsieur le Préfet
madame de La Gonterie avec un micro
votre réponse me
perplexifie ça veut dire que vous n'avez
pas de compéten sur la sur la question
de la sécurité
privée c'est non non c'est
l'organisateur hein qui non mais donc
qui coordonne l'ensemble des dispositifs
de sécurité si c'était pas vous non mais
moi je je d'abord moi je coordonne
touses les forces de sécurité intérieure
sur l'ensemble de la région
Île-de-France en lien évidemment étroit
avec les préfets de département ça c'est
le premier point ensuite la sécurité
privée elle va être essentiellement
engagée par l'organisateur par le COJO
pour ses propres dispositifs de sécurité
c'est-à-dire que le COJO va devoir gérer
ses sites va devoir gérer oui si bien
sûr on est en coordination mais c'est on
se coordonne évidemment en opérationnel
euh mais mais je ne suis pas je n'ai pas
autorité sur ces personnes mais oui on
se coordonne c'est-à-dire que ils vont
être chargés de sécuriser les sites
olympiques ils vont être chargés de
sécuriser leurs flotte ils vont être
chargés de sécuriser les accès au Keba
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture puisque
c'est un périmètre COJO mais nous nous
n'avons pas autorité évidemment sur eux
madame canailler oui merci monsieur le
Président j'ai une dernière petite
question Monsieur le Préfet dans la loi
sur la sécurisation des Jeux Olympiques
nous avons conféré les pouvoirs de
préfet de police sur l'ensemble des cinq
départements durant les Jeux olympiques
mais qui a compté du 1er juillet 2024 or
on voit bien qu'il y a un énorme travail
de préparation
aujourd'hui on voit que dans les
annonces qui ont été faites hier trois
départements sont concernés de deux
autres communiqueront plus tard est-ce
que pour vous il n'y a pas de difficulté
aujourd'hui n'ayant pas encore ses
prérogatives complètes d'harmoniser de
coordonner ce travail
préparatoire non parce que je je suis
préfet de zone donc j'ai déjà un pouvoir
de coordination et puis ça se passe en
bonne intelligence donc vous voyez par
exemple sur ces périmètres on s'est tous
mis d'accord sur le fait qu'on
appliquerait les mêmes règles pour avoir
une une uniformisation de de la gestion
des périmètres sur l'ensemble de la
région non ça pose pas de problème le
plus important c'est que les compétences
qui me sont données sont surtout des
compéten de direction aussi des forces
de police opérationnelles ça a été un
souhait du gouvernement et surtout du
CIO d'avoir un interlocuteur unique sur
une zone où 80 % des jeux ou 85 % des
jeux 26 sites vont se dérouler d'avoir
un interlocuteur unique donc donc à
partir du du du 1er juillet
effectivement je deviens compétent mais
et je et je vais avoir un certain nombre
de police spéciales don donc vous savez
quand il va falloir déroger pour savoir
si on peut survoler un site olympique
dans dans l'ensemble dans dans en tout
point de la région c'est moi qui seraai
compétent mais ça la question va se
poser pendant les Jeux ça ça ça
n'empêche pas de les préparer tous
ensemble sans aucune difficulté ça ne
pose pas de de problème par contre au
moment où les jeux vont débuter d'où ces
dates du 1er juillet au 15 septembre là
effectivement il sera sans doute unu
plus utile de d'exercer effectivement
ces compétences dont une grande partie
seront déléguées en réalité hein donc
dans une grande partie seront délégués
mais en cas de crise en cas de coup dur
il faut toujours qu'il y ait qu'une
personne qui prenne les commandes merci
Monsieur le Préfet j'ai deux demandes de
parole mais j'avais petite question à
tiroir avant à vous poser est-ce que
vous avez une estimation du nombre de
résidents et donc de véhicules qui sont
dans les zones que vous avez délimité
euh déjà a priori donc de personnes
concernées de premier tiroir euh comment
seront prévenus les touristes parce
qu'il y a pas mal d'hôtels dans les
zones qui sont délimitées et même
question pour les touristes qui prendrez
des locations
Airbnb comment seront-ils prévenus pour
s'enregistrer sur la
plateforme et après je passe la parole à
mes
collègues la première question pardon
j'ai l'estimation de oui ah oui
l'estimation alors l'estimation je serai
plus précis euh la prochaine les
véhicule je ne l'ai pas euh mais les
résidents dans la les résidents dans la
zone alors les résidents dans les zones
rouges à Paris je crois de mémoire que
c'est 20000 personnes euh c'est 20000
personnes donc il ont pas tous des
véhicules qui ont pas tous vocation bon
mais tout ça je vérifierai avec la Ville
de Paris et les établissements publics
les établissements pardon commerciaux
les bars resto je crois de mémoire que
c'est 700 dont 1/3 de restaurant mais
tout ça je vais vous le préciser nous
l'avons c'est plutôt la ville de Paris
hein qui a connaissance de ça mais on
n'est pas non plus sur des nombres on
n'est pas sur des nombres illimités de
personnes euh pour les pour les
touristes les personnes qui réserveront
des hôtels d'où l'intérêt de d'arrêter
définitivement les règles fin janvier
hein parce que ce sont les propriétaires
d'hôtel ceux qui louront leur
appartement qui devront faire connaître
aux locataires ou aux clients des hôtels
ces règles-là hein les modalités
d'inscription dont on va discuter avec
les professionnels aussi hein il y a
plusieurs possibilités hein pour les
hôtels soit c'est l'hôtelier qui
enregistre les qui signalent les clients
qui vont venir ce qui nous semble être
la meilleure formule mais on en
discutera évidemment avec l'UMI avec la
profession euh soit euh soit évidemment
ce sont les les les touristes les
clients qui s'enregistrent mais ça peut
être plus compliqué pour eux hein ça
peut plus être compliqué pour eux
d'autant que les atôteliers souvent
disposent de ces informations voilà mais
tout ça ce sera ouvert évidemment euh à
la à la la concertation on discutera
avec les professionnel pour les
plateformes de location c'est part un
accord avec les plateformes envisageable
avec tout ça tout ça tout ça on y
réfléchit c'est sûr que nous on sera
guidé à la fois par des considérations
on aura le le la même philosophie
c'està-dire une approche qui veut qu'on
ne va pas on va on va on va laisser la
vie économique se dérouler normalement
mais en ayant des modalités enfin de de
de contrôle et de vérification qui
seront quand même qui nous permettront
quand même de savoir qui
qui parce que là la question ce dont on
parle c'est que sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture c'est tout on que voilà on
n'est pas ailleurs dans donc voilà mais
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture le sujet
se pose et vous comprenez qu'il faut
quand même qu'on qu'on soit un peu au
courant de qui réside dans les
appartements les chambres
d'hôtel les endroits où on a un visuel
sur la scène c'est un enjeu de sécurité
majeur monsieur André
Richart
merci Président Monsieur le Préfet de
Police moi je suis sénateur du barrain
donc vous savez naturellement que le
cheflieu est Strasbourg ce Strasbourg
qui reçoit chaque année le marché de
Noël je je parle sous le couvert d'un
ancien adjoint qui connaît bien c'est
c'est entre 1 et 2 millions de visiteurs
sur une période de 3 4
semaines ça se passe naturellement dans
différents points Strasbourg
donc ce que vous appelez le cas échéant
sur les Jeux Olympiques des sites voilà
chacun ayant naturellement ses propres
contraintes ses propres difficultés et
cetera et je voudrais vous poser des
questions euh précisément cont tenu de
l'expérience
que je peux avoir maintenant depuis
quelques années soit dit en passant ça
n'a pas envêché l'attentat que vous
connaissez tous qui montre
que rien n'est jamais
parfait
les questions sont dans l'ordre les
suivantes on a bien compris enfin j'ai
bien compris moi vous avez largement
insisté là-dessus que les restrictions
porteraient
essentiellementf quasiment uniquement
sur la circulation
routière pas pas pas les pas les piétons
pas pas les pas les
cycliste cuit de le caséchiant des deux
roues motorisé c'est une première
question mais celle-ci est incidente la
deuxè question est-ce que porte sur les
créneaux horaire de
de d'interdiction enfin de de limite non
d'interdiction pour le coup de de de
circulation pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce
que dans la ville dont je viens de vous
parler les les le marché de Noël
naturellement dure le jour la nuit et
cetera enfin du moins les les les outils
les cabanes sont là et ce en tout ce que
vous vous voyez traditionnellement dans
un marché de Noël certes ils sont fermés
à une certaine heure mais il y a encore
naturellement beaucoup de personnes qui
se déplacent à cette occasion là parce
que c'est une occasion de faire la fête
donc là des créneaux sont créneaux
horaires sont prévus on ouvre
officiellement à telle heure on ferme à
telle heure
et au-delà de cette heure-là les
voitures peuvent accéder bien notamment
pour permettre au au Riverin de de de
garder leur voiture chez eux et cetera
et cetera donc est-il prévu quelque
chose comme cela et le cas échéant
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
informations sur ces horaires si tentz
que il soit déjà déjà fixé immédiatement
derrière se pose la question du
stationnement bien à Strasbourg on va
jusqu'à excusez-moi de prendre cet
exemple mais ça ça ça ça vous donne
naturellement quelques pistes de
réflexion si si vous deviez en manquer
Monsieur le Préfet euh
le stationnement est strictement
interdit du du du actuellement de Têt je
crois que ça a dû commencer le le 22 ou
le 23 novembre jusqu'au 24 décembre à
memi pas de stationnement nulle part
bien ceci pour des raisons qu'on peut
bien comprendre bien donc est-ce qu'il
est prévu quelque chose comme ça j'ai
bien compris qu'à priori le risque porte
essentiellement sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture mais je je je me pose quand
même la question de savoir si dans
d'autres sites autour de autour de
notamment les les les stades concernés
et cetera est-ce que vraiment on peut se
limiter simplement à un périmètre hors
entre guillemets population hors
résident vous semblez dire que oui mais
merci de N le confirmer je voudrais
Infiné vous dire que naturellement cette
ces restrictions sont éminemment
impopulaires vous vous en doutez bien
éminemment impopulaires à telle enseigne
que au fil des années ça fait maintenant
des années qu'on a ce genre de chose le
le marché de Strasbourg prenant une
ampleur absolument terrible vous avez
compris entre 1 et 2 millions voire 2
millions euh la population est excédée
donc elle est excédée par quoi elle est
excédé par les les checkpoints d'entrée
et sortie pour ceux qui bénéficient de
dérogation parce que c'est bien comme ça
qu'il les appelle les checkpoint et et
ils sont excédés par la la la la lenteur
la longueur de ces au début c'est
absolument épouvantable donc moi je
milite naturellement même si ça plaît
pas à d'autres pour une plateforme
d'inscription préalable ça se fait à
Strasbourg mais malheureusement ça
suffit pas vraiment ça ne suffit pas des
gens qui ont leur badge et ils ont leur
badge ont quelque chose dans la voiture
parce que naturellement même s'ils ont
le badge on ouvre quand même le coffre
clairement et il faut le faire enfin
c'est c'est c'est évident donc ça prend
du temps les gens sont excédés les les
les les artisans qui veulent accéder au
centre sont excédés de la même façon
naturellement la moitié d'entre eux ont
oublié de faire la demande sur la
plateforme he je parle de ceux qui qui
ne sont pas de Strasbourg pas les
riverins mais enfin c'est c'est c'est je
suis juste obligé de vous dire que c'est
à l'heure actuelle je actuellement ça a
démarré donc je peux vous en parler
j'entends déjà ce que disent les gens
bien et donc la conclusion de tout ça
c'est et je termine la conclusion de
tout ça ça a été de dire et de toute
façon on n pas empêché l'attentat bien
bah ça vaut pas la peine de continuer
comme ça et d'autant plus allez je
caricature à peine mais je l'entends
tous les jours c'est pour ça je vrais
vous le dire sauf quand je suis à Paris
bien sûr he bien euh on me dit bah
maintenant on a restreint les créneaux
maintenant c'est 11h du matin 20h je
crois c'est quelque chose comme ça bon à
quoi ça sert puisque de nous embêter
comme ça les gens qui veulent commettre
quelque chose ils viennent avant 11h ils
vont poser leur bombes avant ils vont et
cetera et cetera donc ça sert à rien à
telle enseinene que maintenant les je
vais vous dire moi je suis passé à
dimanche matin à 11h moins le car bon
avec un cabat je vou j'ai voulu ouvrir
le cabat les types étaient là ils ont
dit non non c'est pas encore là vous
pouvez passer on regarde pas le CABA
donc je voilà je voudrais simplement
attirer votre attention sur le côté mais
vous le savez bien sur le côté vraiment
sensible de de ce type de démarche et la
nécessité
euh vraiment de de de
allez d'avoir un maximum de bon sens
pour éviter à la fois il faut trouver le
bon équilibre pour éviter à la fois
excusez-moi d'utiliser ce terme
d'emmerder les Français euh et d'un
autre côté de naturellement de sécuriser
au maximum l'événement qui va se passer
excusez-moi d'avoir été long mais et je
suis sûr que vous l'avez déjà fait euh
si vous n'avez pas déjà pris contact
avec Madame la préfè de de de du Grand
Est et du barrain il faut le faire parce
que c'est les enseignements que nous
avons tiré de tout ce qui s'est passé à
Strasbourg depuis des dizaines d'années
pour un événement de grande ampleur hein
je répète hein bien parler de 20000
personnes concernées à Strasbourg c'est
beaucoup plus que ça beaucoup plus que
ça et
et très franchement je voudrais pas
gérer à votre
place monsieur Beatz merci beaucoup
Président Monsieur le Préfet merci euh
de venir à à à nous je pense que les
explications que vous a apporté sont
parfaitement claires et précises et et
j'avoue que moi personnellement ne pas
avoir bien compris les mois suscité par
vos déclarations par la conférence de
presse que vous avez donné au aux
Parisiens alors Marie-Pierre de la
Contrie m'apporte un élément
d'explication effectivement on rentre
dans le principe de réalité pour pour un
certain nombre de de personnes
évidemment le fait d'avoir été candidate
à l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
pour la France et pour la ville de Paris
emporte des conséquences qui vont être
énorme sur la vie quotidienne des des
des Parisiens des Franciliens pendant
cette pendant cette période là et André
richichard parlait à juste titre du du
marché de Strasbourg c'est vrai que
j'étais adjoint chargé de la sécurité à
Strasbourg entre 2008 et 2014 donc
autant dire que même sur un événement
qui a plus de 4 siècles d'existence
André ben le point d'équilibre n'a
toujours pas été trouvé et effectivement
tous les ans il y a des des ajustements
des mesures et on a conscience du du
caractère parfaitement imparfait de
chaque dispositif de de sécurité mais
même effectivement un événement pour
lequel les Strasbourg joois sont
préparés tous les ans ils savent ce qui
va se passer c'est vrai que c'est c'est
c'est très compliqué pour les les les
habitants le supporter mais je une fois
qu'on a dit ça je vois pas bien ce que
l'on peut faire concrètement en tout cas
moi j'ai pas bien compris les
mois suscité et surtout cette injonction
fait à l'autorité administrative on va
dire d'immédiatement enfin de ce soupçon
d'irrégularité juridique de de son
action moi je voilà je trouve ça un
petit peu déplacé on sait qu'on va
rentrer dans des mois qui sont très
difficiles et je trouve qu'il est pas
possible qu'il a des injonctions de
cette naturelà en direction de
l'autorité administrative chaque fois
que le dispositif de sécurité est
précisé parce que sinon on ne s'en
sortira pas collectivement là c'était le
le le premier point que je souhaitais
aborder pour pour dire ensuite que
andréchard parlait du marché de Noël moi
en tant qu'adjoint à la sécurité à
Strasbourg j'ai surtout le souvenir du
sommet de l'OTAN en 2009 évidemment qui
était un événement de de de grand
ampleur où là aussi les mesures
restrictives avaient été extrêmement
fortes il était pas possible qu'il en
soit autrement comme ça étit le cas pour
le le G7 à à à Biaritz mais moi la
question je je souhaitais poser plus
précise et vous y répondrez si si vous
pouvez si vous voulez c'est sur la
question effectivement de cette
dérogation à la circulation automobile
est-ce que le critère d'attribution de
la dérogation sera exclusivement lié à
la nécessité justifiée de pouvoir se
déplacer dans le périmètre ou est-ce
qu'il y aura un criblage évidemment des
personnes qui font la qui font la
demande parce que je crois que c'est
c'est ça la la vraie question euh de de
sécurité aujourd'hui autant vous dire je
sais pas ce qui est juridiquement
possible ou pas mais c'est évident que
lorsqu'on a autant de piétons qui
circulent aux abords des sites des sites
olympiques et paralympiques de faire
rentrer des véhicules c'est un c'est
évidemment un danger euh pour la la
sécurité de de de la population et donc
voilà je c'est une demande de précision
si vous pouvez l'pporter euh que que je
souhaiterais avoir en tout cas moi dans
le le bon sens qu'invoquit André rachart
me pousserait plutôt évidemment être
favorable à ce criblage s'il était
possible qu' sentendre bien je n' verrai
pas du tout une menace pour les les
libertés mais bien au contraire une
sécurisation pour nos concitoyens même
si on sait qu'elle sera jamais parfaite
mais avec des des cartes qui sont et
c'est le principe de la la transparence
donc vous faites preuve et vous avez de
toute façon pas le choix sur le fond
faut bien apporter les éléments mais
vous indiquez des mois à l'avance quel
va être le dispositif les périmètres et
donner ainsi aussi la carte à à
d'éventuels
euh auteurs d'actes d'actes malfaisant
donc par rapport à à à ça cet équilibre
qu'il faut réussir à à trouver euh qui
qui est pas qui est pas évident voilà
est-ce que il y a moyen de de s'assurer
que ces autorisations de circul dans le
périmètre soit bien donné à des
personnes qui ne sont pas déjà connu des
services mais on sait bien que les
services ne connaissent de toute façon
pas tout merci Monsieur B madame
naraassin
merci moi je voudrais déjà commencer par
dire parce que même si Marie-Pierre a
raison de rappeler qu'il y a un principe
de réalité qui fait que il y a des
inquiétudes qui qui montrent que je suis
sénatrice de la saint et si même si ça
s'appelle les Jeux olympiques de Paris
une grande partie d'entre eux se dérou
enenceinte saint-enis et dans ce
département nous sommes très heureux
d'accueillir beaucoup d'événements euh
parce que ça va ça va apporter ça
apporte déjà évidemment de nouvelles
infrastructures et puis et puis il y
aura un héritage qu'on espèera bénéfique
pour le département sur le long terme et
puis ça sera aussi quand même un moment
de fête parce qu' aujourd'hui les gens
ralent mais quand on va commencer à
quand on aura on sera dans le moment de
de de la cérémonie je pense que il y a
une atmosphère générale qui fait que
aussi euh euh la le le point de vue
changera y compris pour les habitants et
et surtout dans la mesure où vous jouez
pleinement votre rôle qui est de de
rendre les choses euh de de sécuriser de
de de d'apporter la tranquillité
d'esprit à chacun sans entraver euh
justement le bon déroulement des
opérations bien au contraire et on sait
que même s'il y a eu effectivement des
épisodes dramatiques avec avec la coupe
la la la la finale de la de la Champions
League il y a aussi eu beaucoup
d'événements qu'on s'est très bien
organisé très réussis et et ne serait-ce
que dans les dernières années l'Euro
2016 ou ou encore plus récemment la
Coupe du monde de rugby euh donc ma
question est est est
donc et quand même plus sur cette
question des des périmètres sur la scène
saint-is on a quand même une inquiétude
dans la la manière dont les choses se
mettent en place qui est que il y a
énormément d'hébergements euh d'urgence
en scèin notamment pour certains très
près des sites olympiques et que même si
les périmètres vont filtrer
essentiellement la la circulation
automobile le fait qu'il a une présence
de police extrêmement forte peut
décourager beaucoup de ces personnes en
situation de précarité euh d'aller vers
ses hébergements d'urgence et donc de se
retrouver
euh dans la rue dans voilà donc sans
sans la possibilité ou ou en craignant
de passer les barrages de police pour
aller dans les endroits où ils seront
accueillis et où ils pourront passer la
nuit et donc je voulais savoir comment
est-ce que vous comptez aussi euh
prendre en compte cette
questionl Monsieur le Préfet et
après euh donc sur toutes les questions
qui m'ont été posées d'abord que
monsieur le sénateur du du du Barin sur
les deau motorisé elles seront traité
elles seront traité comme les véhicules
hein donc les deau
motorisé ne seront interdites dans les
périmètres rouges de circulation
uniquement il faudra obtenir une
dérogation euh les créneaux horaires
sont prévus hein effectivement on active
ces périmètres
que enfin 2h30 avant le début des
compétitions et on on les on les
désactive 1 heure après la fin des
compétitions voilà mais tout ça on va
évidemment le c'est ce qui est prévu on
va en discuter mais là ce sont plutôt
dans la cadre de la concertation là
c'est calé sur les heures de compétition
moi je peux pas les changer j'ai pas ce
pouvoir donc ça on sera ce sont les
horaires qui je pense sont sans doute
définitivement retenu il y a pas de
raison qu'on bouge les choses c'est pas
comme la le le le la cartographie des
des des périmètres ou les conditions des
é en droits euh alors évidemment le
village olympique en sa s lui c'est H24
he voilà donc il y a quand même des
sites qui vont être ou la cérémonie
d'ouverture ce sera plusieurs jours
avant et ce sera nonstop évidemment mais
ça ce sont plus des exceptions mais qui
seront effectivement contraignante hein
le le périmètre rouge le le j'étais hier
avec le maire de Saint-Denis qui me
disait dans le périmètre rouge sur sa
commune c'est quelques milliers de
personnes quand même hein donc voilà euh
sur les le stationnement dans cette zone
rouge euh ce sont des choses qu'on va
réglementer par la suite hein là
aujourd'hui pour le coup je ne sais pas
répondre à cette question mais
effectivement on le prévoit toujours
c'estd dans cette zone de restriction
d'interdiction de circulation il peut y
avoir des mesures de stationnement qui
sont prises en plus pour faciliter les
flux de piéton comme on fait lors des
manifestation on demande évidemment ce
qu'il n'est pas de voiture dans l'avenue
ça on y'y a pas encore travaillé c'est
beaucoup trop tôt c'est beaucoup trop
trôt et c'est c'est aussi pour cela
qu'on de qu'on autorise les riverins à
rentrer dans ces périmètres en véhicule
uniquement lorsqu'ils ont des parkings
privés parce que si on les autorisait à
stationner sur la voie publique il
pourrai stationner sur des endroits que
nous on souhaite voir libre dans ce
périmètre qui est encore fois un
périmètre où les piétons vont circuler
notamment les spectateurs des des jeux
euh et sur le ce que vous disiez
effectivement sur la gestion desck
checkpoint comme vous dites à à
Strasbourg c'est c'est tout le débat
qu'on a sur la plateforme hein c'est le
bon sens versus emmerder les gens quoi
comme je reprends votre expression je me
permets mais voilà moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'une plateforme c'est moins ennuyer
les gens parce que on a une fois une
fois pour toute d'abord on s'enregistre
en ligne c'est beaucoup plus rapide et
puis pour un Riverin il a une fois pour
toute son autorisation voilà j'ai j'ai
le sentiment que le bon sens plaide
plutôt vers la mise en place d'une
plateforme mais vous avez raison il faut
pas qu' il faut que ce soit fluide il
faut pas que les gens attendent sinon ça
sera très pénible pour les
fonctionnaires de police et encore plus
pour les personnes qui seront autorisées
à y rentrer et qui devront faire faire
la queue
euh l'ouverture des coffres de véhiculle
c'est parce que les véhicules à
Strasbourg rentrent dans le périmètre de
protection hein donc le périmètre rouge
n'est pas un périmètre de protection au
sens lo sililt c'est pas donc je réponds
je réponds doublement aux questions il y
a pas forcément de fouille du véhicule
hein et et a il y a pas de criblage et
il y a pas de criblage évidemment on
n'est pas sur une zone on n'est pas sur
une zone couverte par le le décret grand
événement en en tout cas à ce stade et
je ne le demande pas hein donc on n'est
pas on n'est pas il y a pas de criblage
il y a pas de fouille forcément de
véhicule après sur réquisition du
procureur parce qu'on a connaissance
d'une menace évidemment on pourra nous
demander un 78 du code de procédure
pénale 2 parce qu'on a une menace
connaissance d'une menace précise on
pourra faire ouvrir les coffres mais
mais il faudrait qu'il y ait une menace
et qu'on le justifie que ça peut être
sur acquisition du procureur ça n'est
pas que ça ne sera pas un silte hein je
pense que la différence avec le marché
de Strasbourg elle se situé à ce
niveau-là et donc je réponds en même
temps à votre question monsieur le
sénateur non il a pas il y aura pas de
criblage juridiquement ça n'est pas
possible et je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
inclure les périmètres de circulation
dans le décret grand événement pourquoi
parce que nous n'allons contrôler de
toute façon que les véhicules qui
rentrent c'estd vérifier qu'ils peuvent
passer mais les piétons les vélos
rentreront librement donc vous voyez ce
serait une mesure qui serait qui serait
pas forcément pertinente parce que les
les les piétons eux passeraient sans
sans contrôle excusemi je permet de
préciser la question question c'était
par rapport à au possible utilisation de
de voiture en terme comme arme par
destination comme voiture bélier et donc
de s'assurer que la la la personne
effectivement ne soit pas déjà connue
voilà c'est tout ce que je veux d'ord
non non je je comprends bien le sens
mais voilà juridiquement ça n'est pas
possible et vous pensez que ça serait
utile je je pour pouvoir le faire il
faudrait le le le il faudrait que il
faudrait que le décret grand événement
inclut mes périmètres de mes zones de
sécurité mes périmètres mais euh avec le
décret grand événement comme vous le
savez vous ne pouvez pas cribler tout le
monde hein donc ce sont euh c'est voilà
euh donc on peut pas cribler tout le
monde il y a des conditions très
strictes donc je ne suis même pas sûr
que ce soit utile voilà mais bon voilà
je je à ce stade je ne pense pas que ce
soit possible juridiquement et sur la
dernière question sur le madame sur le
effectivement ça typiquement ce sont des
questions euh qu'il faudra voir dans le
cadre de la concertation il serait
important que chaque maire indique les
établissements de ce genre qui sont
situés dans le périmètre rouge et qu'on
prévoit des des des dispositions
appropriées mais évidemment que euh ce
que ces personnes se rendent à pied dans
ces centres donc il y y a il y a aucune
raison queelles en soient empêché mais
tout ça c'est des ce sont typiquement
dans le cadre de la consultation avec
chaque élu CE sont c'est à eux de de
signaler aussi ce type d'établissement
comment on va le gérer et comment les
choses vont se passer pour que ce soit
pour je reprends le propos de Monsieur
le Sénateur pour qu'on soit dans le plus
dans le dans on reste dans le bon sens
c'est ça le bon sens et moi j'ai un
autre impératif et je vous remercie
monsieur
le sénateur de l'avoir de l'avoir
souligné c'est aussi l'impératif de
sécurité hein
et voilà et merci monsieurénateur pour
monsieur le sénateur pour vos propos
mais je je quand bien même cette
audition était vraiment programmée par
ailleurs évidemment si j'avais été
invité convoqué ou je ne sais que quoi
pour ne parler que de ce qui s'est passé
hier je serais quand même venu he n'ayez
crainte
hein dernière intervenant madame Floren
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Préfet je rejoins ce qu'a
dit mon collègue bits sur les mois qui a
pu
susciter vos vos propos hier et vous
redire que moi en tant que franilienne
alttoquanz plutôt on est plutôt attentif
et pour la population attentif aussi à
la sécurité qui sera apportée pour ces
pour ces événements et sur les lieux
justement
concernés moi je vous remercie également
pour la concertation mise en place parce
que je pense que c'est une bonne chose
que de l'anticiper et évidemment vous
l'avez compris il faudra de la pédagogie
mais euh s'il y a de la concertation et
de l'association aussi des acteurs
locaux je pense qu'on on pourra
travailler avec les élus locaux en sens
moi j'avais une une question liée enfin
tout simplement parce que c'est pas la
quand même la première fois que des Jeux
Olympiques se se déroule dans une
capitale d'un d'un grand pays et je
voulais savoir justement quelle leçon et
si vous les aviez tiré et si vous
inspiriez de ce qui a pu être fait
notamment et des difficultés d'ailleurs
quand on reprend l'histoire en terme de
sécurité rencontré au préalable pas
durant les compétitions mais avant à
Londres en 2012 parce que on sait très
bien qu'en terme de sécurité ça a pas
été simple sur l'OND et éventuellement à
Rio après en tout cas est-ce qu'à chaque
fois il a y a une continuité en tout cas
une analyse j'imagine quand même sur sur
l'expérience et sur l'apprentissage même
si les conditions sont pas tout à fait
les mêmes notamment pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture merci Monsieur richchard
pour 10 secondes voilà j'avais oublié de
vous poser une question Monsieur le
Préfet de police si on passe si on passe
par une plateforme comme proposer euh
avez-vous une idée de la la durée de
stockage des données dans cette
plateforme euh je je je sais pas du tout
comment ça se passe à Strasbourg pour
revenir à cela je suis pas persuadé que
ce soit la police nationale d'ailleurs
qui crée cela je sais pas bien donc
voilà et et dernière et ultime
intervenant madame de La Gonterie oui
c'est pas une question c'est c'est un
petit peu un mot de conclusion euh parce
que vous avez compris que moi aussi je
j'avais un peu été surprise par les mois
provoqués même si je trouve toujours
positif que les sénateurs se préoccupent
des libertés publiques euh c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important mais
je c'est du premier degré ce que je dis
euh et que quand même on peut saluer le
fait que on est à 239 jours non
j'imagine que dans votre bureau vous
avez
un donc je crois qu'on est à 239 jours
et donc avoir aussi en amont toutes ces
informations et cetera c'est quelque
chose de formidable donc il faut voir
les choses de manière un peu posi
Monsieur le
Préfet avec 239
cases Monsieur le Préfet alors et lui
seul merci madame de laterie pour vos
propos je crois avant de répondre au
questions mais il il est logique
que on s'attend au fur à mesure qu'on va
dérouler nos plan de sécurité évidemment
on s'attend ce qu'on a beaucoup de
questions et et et on s'y prépare et en
tout cas moi je vous redis que je suis à
la disposition de la mission hein pour
venir exposer à échéance régulière la
façon dont on on met en place nos
dispositifs de sécurité madame la
sénatrice donc sur le le oui on a
connaissance évidemment parce que
d'abord moi j'ai des collaborateurs qui
sont aller à Londres voir comment les
choses s'étaient passées pour avoir des
rtex on travaille beaucoup avec le CIO
aussi hein qui d'ailleurs qui est qui
est là en ce moment le président est là
en ce moment et demain nous planchons
avec Monsieur Michel Cado le délégué
interministaire le jeu lui et moi allons
plancher sur ces sujets devant le CO qui
à échéance régulière vient nous demander
comment les choses avancent comment ça
se passe et ce qu'ils nous disent je je
le répète parce que ce ce qu'il nous
disent c'est que nous sommes
parfaitement dans les délais sur les
questions de sécurité et tout sur tous
les autres sujet mais moi je parle de ce
que je connais et qu'il n'y a pas de
difficulté particulière il faut bien
l'avoir en tête et le CIO dans d'autres
capital contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre ces jours derniers il y a eu
aussi des restrictions de circulation
bien plus lourde que celle que nous
mettons en place hein donc voilà et et
et quand on nanticipe pas les choses les
restrictions se mettent parfois d'ell
même en place dans les faits de facto
elles se mettent en place donc voilà
donc on travaille beaucoup avec le
coio on a beaucoup de retours
d'expérience aussi de leur part sur des
événements euh qui qui qui qui peuvent
avoir des impacts sur la sécurité mais
qui sont liés finalement à la vie
olympique nous connait pas forcément
cette vie olympique les Jeux Olympiques
euh des d'entre les transports
d'athlètes la façon dont se comportent
les délégations et cetera donc il nous
donne beaucoup d'informations oui et on
a des échanges vraiment voilà on a le
rtex de tous les jeux et les échanges
sont sont très fluides sur la durée de
conservation des données c'est celle de
l'arrêter c'est le maximum 3 mois mais
en général enfin pour ce genre de pour
ce genre de plateforme on a pas besoin
d'une durée très très longue hein voilà
c'est le maxi est prévu par par l'arrêté
c'est 3 mois euh après bon les les vous
avez quand même une période de jeu qui
qui qui qui qui fait entre dans la zone
de Paris Centre entre la cérémonie
d'ouverture et donc le dispo qui va se
mettre en place plusieurs jours avant et
la fin des jeux avec les paralympiques
on est quand même sur une période qui
fait un mois et demi là un bon mois et
demi donc voilà mais dans d'autres zones
ce sera moins nécessaire de il y a des
sites d'ailleurs qui n'ont vocation qu'à
exister que pour les les jeux olympique
et qu'on ne retrouve pas donc pour les
Jeux paralympiques hein donc Jeux
Olympiques jeux paralympiqu il a il y a
deux sites qui disparaissent notamment
le Trocadero et un site dans le
92 merci Monsieur le Préfet merci chers
collègues la séance est
levée